- On this episode, we talk Twitch,
Mike Tyson's Punch-Out!!, and Zelda.
But it's not a video game show.
(pulsing hip-hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 131
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
First I wanna say Sid, I love you,
this is it for the summer,
I'm actually devastated
that you're leaving,
so thanks for being here for the summer.
I want to say that
the golden era is over
and we are now going into the dark ages,
and I'm really looking forward to it.
I'm about to spend a lot
of time with my family,
so the show
the show will be a little
more infrequent here
towards the end of August
through Labor Day, so
you're going to realize how
much you love this thing,
you know, the heart grows fonder, Steve.
Steve and I and the people at Wine Library
have been working, flip it, Steve.
We are working hardcore.
DRock, you don't have to zoom in,
let's make an image for it
overlaying so it looks better.
See? Much easier.
@WineDeals on Instagram,
the only way to buy wine
in America period.
(laughter)
Yeah, I'm excited about it.
So, no, we're hacking, you know,
I'm excited for this being
a business context show.
First of all, if you love wine at all,
or are into it or buy
wine at the supermarket,
you should check it out,
'cause we're being ridiculous,
I'll be very transparent with you.
The first hundred days
of deals are gonna be
much, much better than later on
because I'm trying to win early
on, so it's gettin' great.
That Chateauneuf-Du-Pape
thing you bought was sick.
Number two, I'm gonna be able to,
and I'm learning in real time,
remember, the thing I
take the most pride in is
I'm a practitioner,
we are learning a ton
about Instagram commerce,
and I will be sharing
those things with you,
it might be a good idea to ask questions
about Instagram commerce going forward.
India, you and I were just talking
before we started the show
about rounding out and finishing
up the #AskGaryVee book,
so we're gonna be coming to
you on Facebook and Instagram
on the feed to ask questions
around certain categories,
so you'll be seeing that
shortly, that's exciting.
- Very exciting.
- Yesterday we spoke in Hoboken.
- Oh yeah.
- That was a good talk, right?
- It was great.
- Was there some new stuff?
- Oh, I don't have time.
Don't have money.
Woe is me.
- There was a couple different things,
I mean, it's always the same, but -
- Stop watching (censored)
entire seasons of (censored)
you know, House of Cards -
- There was some stuff.
- You were very fired up.
- I don't give a (censored).
- I was, right?
- Yeah, oh yeah. It was great.
- DRock, we got some good
stuff for footage, right?
- Literally, like, really?
Like, you've got time for Angry Birds
and you're complaining?
Get the (censored) out of here.
- Awesome. So all right, India.
What else did I want to - ooh! Oh.
I need to do some right-hooking
for my homies at VaynerMedia.
South by Southwest, this will be
the first time that I'm
not the only one speaking,
a bunch of the VaynerMedia people
have submitted panels, but they need,
see, unlike me, who's a boss.
Right? Say it with me.
Let's do it, "boss" together.
- I'm not gonna say that.
- [Gary] Say "boss".
- I'm not gonna do that.
- Okay.
(laughter)
Unlike me, who just gets slotted in
because I can draw,
these characters at Vayner need some votes
to actually get their
panels selected, right?
So DRock, let's link it up
for them in Facebook and
YouTube, don't forget,
'cause you forgot the
Facebook link the other day,
yes, okay, thank you, DRock.
Don't forget the links.
When you're editing and
watching, you should just,
oh, but, anyway.
And so what do we have, like,
three or four different panels, right?
- Three panels.
- Yeah, so.
- And they're gonna be great.
You should vote for Vayner,
because the panels are gonna be amazing.
very exciting.
- Yeah, so,
I would appreciate it,
that will make them really feel happy,
they've been asking me for a
little love, can you tweet,
no, I'm not gonna tweet, I'm gonna
I'm gonna activate the Vayner Nation.
And so I know you guys
will come through for them
and so that means a lot to me,
if I have the emoji that
does this right here,
I would do that.
My Snapchat game, as a matter
of fact, you know what?
Let's do it in real time.
See, this was a clever
kind of content play.
My Snapchat game is
my Snapchat game is really leveling up,
Sid, Andrew, India, Steve.
So I'm enjoying that, the
Snapchat stuff has been fun.
And that's it, that's kind of
my roundup to start the show.
- [India] Plastic.
- Oh! Thank you.
Yes, you know,
I don't know if you like
cool stickers on laptops,
clearly Stunwin does,
but this might be a very
good thing to go check out.
A lot of you are taking advantage of that,
a bunch of you are just not smart enough
to take advantage of it.
I laugh and mock your intellect.
(laughter)
And so that's that,
and so, alright, India,
let's get into
- The show.
- The show!
- [India] Trying some new things.
(laughter)
- Gotta mix it up, right?
- [Voiceover] Terrell asks,
"How would you manage pro bono work
"versus getting paid as a startup,
"or how do you draw the
line between the two?"
- I think the question, I
think what I'm getting from it
is, you know, how do you
manage the people asking
you do to stuff on spec?
And it's funny, we've
had some conversations,
I'm a fan of spec, because
I think it's a gateway drug
into showing work.
When you're at zero,
when you have no track record,
when you have no leverage,
spec is a tremendous
opportunity, it's, you're at bat.
And so, spec has always been
interesting in design work
or other things of that nature.
Any time I even allude to a
spec interplay on Twitter,
I get attacked, right?
Like, if I want free t-shirts
for the Great Wall of Wine Deals,
right, stickers, why
don't you pay for them?
I'm thrilled to pay.
As a matter of fact, in my later years,
AKA in the last three years,
I've learned, actually,
I'd rather pay than what I deal with
when somebody gives you,
like, a sticker for free
and they want, like, so, I'm into paying.
I actually, when I do these
spec things, look at it as
the first opportunity to
somebody to have in at bat,
to, like, change the course of their game.
We've alluded this question-answer
with DRock in the past,
like, this is just real to me.
So where do you draw the line is,
when you stop thinking
it brings you value.
By the way, nobody's forcing
you into doing pro bono work.
Hey, DRock, you wanna make a film with me?
You should do it, I'm not gonna
pay you, you should do it.
I didn't force him, like,
you know, that's on you.
So this notion of pro
bono work being, like,
some sort of forced behavior that like,
the rich are forcing the
poor to do this work,
in a world where you
should always do everything
predicated on what brings you value,
including when you bring
other people value.
See, the dirty little secret is, for me,
this 51-49 thing where I
wanna do all these things,
it makes me feel good.
It might not make me more money,
It's a selfish act.
People say that, you
know, you hear it's like,
oh, it's a selfless
act, like, I understand.
I like the way it feels.
And so, you know, your pro bono work
might be because you wanna use it
as a gateway drug to business
opportunities in the future,
or you just might like the way it feels.
That's on you.
But, you know, business is simple,
and this is a business show
in the scheme of things,
so I expect this to be
where you're coming from.
Look, you have to ask.
You can't be scared to ask for money.
You have to ask, and you
have to price yourself,
and you have to price yourself
in a way that makes you feel good.
And so whether that's $100
an hour, $500 an hour,
and the other thing I would tell you is
let the market say no.
I think a lot of people are
too scared to go too high,
and we talked about this on
another show not too long ago,
like, you know, just ask for the money
and go as high as you possibly can,
they can always say no,
you're never gonna say,
"it's gonna cost you $500"
for your R&amp;D, or anything like that,
$500 for your voice-over
work, Stunwin, you know,
"I want $100 an hour," nobody's gonna say,
"cool, we're gonna give you 125."
And so, you know, you're
better off saying 200,
they're like, "ah, we'll give you $120,
and you're like, yes, I only wanted 100.
Thanks, Gary Vee.
(laughter)
You liked that one?
- [Steve] I was tickled by that.
- Such a Stunwin word.
Oh, India, we are idiots!
- [India] We forgot our shirts!
- But good job picking up
on what I was referring to.
You are pissing me off, India.
- [India] Oh my god.
(laughter)
- [Gary] I told you
yesterday, do not forget,
you just were like -
- [India] There's a lot going on.
- We were gonna wear our show t-shirts.
I don't know, I haven't
even opened my boxes,
but it was gonna be you wearing
it that was gonna remind me.
I know, Sid, you wanna go and get it,
but don't worry about
it, let's keep going.
Nope, Sid, you sit here.
Let's go.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Greentalk
asks, "I noticed @NJTech
"that your staff was really young.
"I didn't see anybody
over 40 surrounding you.
Why?"
- Well, India is actually 44,
she just looks phenomenal.
(laughter)
I mean, so there's that.
You know, yeah, my staff is young,
you know, I think I get
value out of mentoring,
though I'm mentoring a lot of people now
that are in their 30s and 40s and 50s.
Yeah, my team happens to be young,
I'm more than open to hiring anybody,
race, credence, you know, like, anything,
it just hasn't happened.
The company's young.
I mean, like, you know, look,
it's kinda one of these things like,
stereotypes, there's some truth to it?
Look, I mean,
this company started doing
social media marketing
in 2009, '10, '11,
like, the 60-year-olds weren't rolling in.
You know? And so
I just think a lot of people
overthink these things,
meaning, like, you know, for example,
a lot of people around
me are always, like,
wanting me to stage things,
for photos, for
interviews, for on my team,
you know, like, all this stuff, like,
I'm aware that India's
the female on my team.
Like, I'm aware of stuff.
I'm aware of everything.
I just also think authenticity rules,
and so I'll be answering your question
in the question that's
the broader question.
You know, I'm pumped to
have anybody on my team.
Listen, and they will all attest to this,
I love standing in front of the company
and saying, look, I'm 39,
I'm the old man on the team
and I'm better at social
media than all of you.
Like, I truly believe that.
I don't pre-judge on age,
sex, where you're from,
well, actually,
I do judge a little bit
on where you're from,
meaning if you're from the
streets I do value you more.
I do like a little bit of
the grind and the hustle.
It's an absolute truth.
It's so funny, the true
one place where I think
more than the cliche things
of age or sex or race,
where I'm a little prejudiced,
is I value the streets.
I just do.
And the streets, AKA just struggling.
I just, I'm a fan of it.
Anyway
yeah, just, it's been
the serendipity of it.
The team has been built from people,
a little bit less, actually,
so that's not true, like,
India and Steve were here,
and I guess the rest of the team, so four,
were hired for us, so yeah,
it's an interesting
thought, like, I'm into it.
I'm super into it.
Apply.
(laughter)
Doc Shelton might, I love Doc.
- [India] Valentina?
- You know, Doc is
hardcore early Wine Lib,
do you remember with Doc and Wine Lib?
Yeah, Doc is the man.
- [Voiceover] Valentina asks,
"What's the next big move for YouTube
"to keep its content
creators from switching over
"if Facebook starts
sharing its revenue too?"
- I don't think there's a
move for it being either/or,
I think all YouTube stars will be on both.
And I think in two
years, there'll be people
that come from Facebook and,
I'm actually thinking about
betting more on YouTube lately,
in a weird way.
And I feel like, and DRock
made a face, it's because,
you know, I feel like I understand
what I wanna do rhythm-wise in Facebook,
and like from an ad-targeting
and from a content standpoint,
and like, I'm like, huh,
you know, YouTube's easy.
There's a lot of people
who've already achieved it.
It's like this wonderful
gal who I met in LA
that you guys are gonna talk
to about the Facebook group,
she's been jamming on it for seven years.
That's established.
Like, it's actually fun to
go into something established
'cause there's some sort of blueprint
and you can just jam on it.
So I think that
YouTube will lose some of its
stars to sharing on Facebook
because it's about reach.
The reason YouTube stars
like being on television,
even though they're digital natives,
is it's just more awareness.
Like, if you're a YouTube
star, that's what you want.
Like, you want more people
watching you. Right?
And there are a lot of
eyeballs on Facebook,
and when these YouTube stars
stop getting romantic
about YouTube and being sad
and realize how targeted they can be
in who they reach on Facebook,
they will be a-coming.
And so it's not gonna be
about what they can do,
and look, then you get
into a networks war.
Like, the platforms are
becoming the networks.
The internet is the whole pipe,
and then there's the
platforms that are networks.
So imagine YouTube and
Facebook and Snapchat
like NBC, Fox, and CBS.
You can do something about it, YouTube.
You're gonna have to pay, shmooty-pie,
you know, a drillion
dollars to stay exclusive.
So that's gonna be very interesting.
I know it's PewDiePie and I'm havin' fun.
Ooh, video.
- Daniel.
- Hey Gary, this is
Dan from Fan-View here.
I hope I make the cut to the golden age
of the #AskGaryVee Show in this format,
and my question,
my question to you is
if you believe that sports teams will
begin to use the rich data
from the influencer market,
all the companies that are coming in
with amazing stats around athletes,
to use that data to start
to play marketing moneyball
with their teams.
I'll love to hear your thoughts on that,
thank you for giving back, peace!
- Marketing moneyball, right?
Yes.
Will sports teams use data
to make better marketing decisions?
Yes.
And I know that I'm, like,
keeping it basic, but, like,
first of all, cool-ass video.
Second of all, very
basic question, meaning
all of marketing will use data
to make better decisions.
Moneyball is the notion
of using data in baseball,
data is going to be used
in every part of our
world everywhere forever,
marketing happens to be one of them,
dating is, you know, if
you think about, like -
oh.
(laughter)
Anyway, dating is one of them.
A lot of things
(laughter)
a lot of things will be that way
and so I think that data will
be overlaid across everything,
and marketing's actually already here,
and there are teams doing it already,
and we've done stuff like that
for the Jets and the Dolphins already,
so yes.
- [Voiceover] Joe asks,
"Can you explain to my 13-year-old son
"that Meerkat and Periscope
are dominating streaming
"while Twitch is being left in the dust?"
- Joe, I can't do that, my friend.
I actually think your 13-year-old's
got your number here, my friend.
So Twitch, which plays in
the e-sports kind of realm,
in my opinion, is dramatically bigger
than Meerkat and Periscope,
where they have figured out
their content very easily,
which is, it is now a foregone conclusion
that million of people will
sit for trillions of hours
and watch other people game.
That is done. It's over.
Now we are in the beginning
stages of that 100%,
meaning in 20 years, more people will
watch the e-sports championship
than the world series.
And it may not even be close.
So, you know, I think
your 13-year-old's got
your number, mister.
Now, will there be
personalities that break out
on Periscope, Meerkat, Facebook Live,
and have real great things happen?
Absolutely.
But, Twitch, you know,
it's a concise value prop,
and so it's kind of like ESPN versus NBC.
NBC's at the mercy of
original content and
stars breaking through,
because they can go anywhere,
AKA Meerkat and Periscope.
Twitch is varied full-down
into, this is the value prop,
and it's a big space, a la ESPN, like,
people like sports, it's
got its niche, it's there.
I actually think he's got you cooked.
It's actually not even close.
I think your 13-year-old
punked you in the face.
(laughter)
What do you think, Steve?
- You expressed it about as
well as I could have hoped for.
- [Gary] Good. You watch a lot of?
- [Steve] I watch more Twitch
than any other online medium.
- How many hours a week?
- Oh, god, if I tell you that,
you'd fire me, wouldn't you?
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- No, I mean -
- [Gary] Tell the truth.
Tell the show, I'm really curious.
- It's on my second monitor, like,
- [Gary] Stop hatching, Steve.
(laughter)
- I don't know, like, maybe
an hour a night? Two hours a night?
(Gary groans)
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding!
No, no, by the way, it's
pretty amazing, though.
Guys, I,
in my venture-capitol behavior,
e-sports is now at the top.
I'm a big fan, so.
Anyway, good show.
I like this new, like, this
is a new era, as we know,
and (laughs) are we gonna "era" all these?
I don't wanna do, no more "era".
We'll never say the word era again.
Era.
Shake monster!
Just kidding.
Okay. Question of the Day:
What is your all-time favorite video game,
non-mobile games, that's
a whole 'nother space,
I actually think that's
gonna be a thing, but
video game. Console. Classic.
Not even PC, which is
considered much more respectful,
but I'm an average gamer
type of guy, you know, like
Nintendo, second genesis,
you know, that kind of stuff.
India, what's your all-time
favorite video game?
- Mm, probably
probably Ocarina of Time on the N64.
- Very nice. Drew?
- NBA Hang Time.
- [Gary] Nice.
On what?
- Great game.
Nintendo.
- [Gary] Got it.
Nintendo, what Nintendo,
you mean Nintendo 64?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Right?
- [Gary] Well, you're so young,
you think Nintendo 64 is Nintendo.
You disgust me.
- I call it that.
- [Gary] Sid?
- FIFA.
- [Gary] On? What year?
The current one?
(unintelligible)
Okay.
- It has to be on a
console, though, not a PC?
- [Gary] Yes. Yes.
- Ocarina of Time, what India said.
- [Gary] Wow.
- The Citizen Kane of video games.
- Wow, I know it's super
respected, I've seen the list,
and remember, I used to buy
these games at garage sales
and flip 'em, so I've
got a good understanding,
which leads me to my answer, which is
Mike Tyson's Punch-Out!!.
It just, it was such a
good, that Christmas,
and Hanukkah was early that
year, so I had it first,
it was like (makes explosion noise).
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip-hop music)